hello everybody welcome
uh good to see you here
i'm grandmaster mircha parley grass and
[Music]
today i'm going to talk about the
stalemate
stalemate alert so
what is uh what is 10 making just
standmate
is the the situation
when one
one player that
has no legal moves to make and his king
is not
uh he's not in check and then the game
is uh
is declared a draw hello hello everybody
so usually stand mate happens
when there are a few pieces left on the
board obviously since
the the fewer the pieces the the higher
the probability
and um it's a
it's a good weapon in the for defense in
in endings for example and uh not only
as uh
as we will see today
yes yes even that if if a game is lost
try to go for for a stainless trick
that's a good that's a good piece of
advice that
we're going to and we're going to see
some
examples we did today hello hello people
good to see you here so i'm going to
start with the
some kind of fun facts
um let's say trivia
and i'm going to show you how we can
reach
the uh the quickest
statement of course both both sides
need to cooperate and it can be reached
in
just 10 moves
so let's see something like e3
the fastest statement yes it's in test
in it's in
10 moves so e3 a5
[Music]
queen h5
well the moves don't really make so much
sense
but we'll just get to the position so
trust me it's 10 moves yeah in just 10
moves it's
it's unbelievable and look at this okay
i will not i'll not uh
i'll not commentate on these moves they
they just prepared the final statement
so look at this queen h7 queen goes to
d3 and then
queen h7 just you can imagine how the
position is going to be
king here and probably a queen there so
there we go
queen e6 amazing and it's a stalemate
so in just 10 moves it's possible to to
reach this one and
uh sam lloyd was the composer that that
found this
uh i don't know in in what year but sam
lloyd is an
america was an american uh just
problemist and he he discovered this
so yeah pretty pretty amazing and now
i just by looking at this position i i
cannot believe how
how it's even possible to to reach it
um i guess it's the fastest
i mean i didn't really try to i didn't
really try to find a
uh faster statement but
i guess this is the fastest i mean how
could it be that
there could be a faster one nine moves
should be so
but anyway this was uh this was ten
moves
uh now let's move on to
hello hello uh to something else
um a mutual statement well of course
the game is over when uh decide to move
is not in check and is running out of
moves
cannot move doesn't have any legal move
but sometimes it happens that there is
mute
mutual uh reciprocal statement like
both uh both sides don't have a move
and i'm going to show you the fastest uh
such
stalemate it was found by uh
enzo minerva so
maybe maybe i will just i'll just show
the
no sorry maybe i'll just show the final
position
because uh yeah okay so
let's see it's in 18 modes let's see
around here
there we go again some moves
and yeah you're probably wondering how
do we reach this
uh this statement where nobody can move
and look at this bishop is three
and then pawn takes and we got it so it
takes
18 moves to reach a
mutual statement so
okay now it's white to move and there
are no
no no moves available for white but also
if it were
black to move then again no legal moves
so very very interesting only 18
18 moves it can be reached okay i didn't
show you from the beginning because it's
just uh
it's just crazy like moves that don't
don't really make
make much sense um
but yeah i wanted to
i wanted to to show you these fun facts
about uh fastest stalemates and we have
another interesting one
i mean probably you are wondering what
what happens or how is the fastest
stalemate with uh all the pieces on the
board
how about that and uh you can write in
the chat
how many moves you you think such a
such a sta it it could be the fastest
way to achieve it and it was found by
charles wheeler
and it's actually pretty fast but yeah
25 30 no it's much less it's the fastest
13 yes very close very close yeah
around there they managed to
charge wheeler managed to get it in only
12 moves amazingly enough
well i'm going to show it to you this
one
again the moves don't uh 12 moves yes uh
the moves don't make much sense
okay these are at least they don't
they're not giving anything for now
but it will be required a bit later to
look at this look at this how to create
how to create a stainless pattern and
with all the pieces on the board so now
is not allowed to take any any piece and
yet to create to manage to create a
stalemate i mean
out the
i'd find it very difficult so
to do it but look at this
and here it's almost it's almost there
e3 c4 and the final touch
you can write in the chat what's the
final move
how to how to achieve the stay mate
f4 very good very good and very nice
and 12 moves yes
really really amazing really amazing and
uh
very very fun position obviously this
will not happen
as i said uh this will not happen in
in over the board games and usually i
like to
i like to show you um
some practical uh ways to to use the
stand mate
uh but it's just that i couldn't help to
to show you these nice
stalemates this records uh because they
are
they are quite amazing so it had to be
done
look at this position how to do it
well they had to think about it it's uh
it's amazing but yeah it's
possible
all right now that we started with this
fastest examples now let's uh let's go
to
to some endings and
[Music]
where it's a good way to
to use the stalemate in order to
[Music]
um to save the to save the game
so white is going this way up
and black is going this way
black is to move and
[Music]
what do you think about this position i
mean
black is uh black is bound to lose the
c5 pawn
because he he loses the opposition here
and white king will come and take the c5
pawn
and probably i mean i didn't really i
didn't really search but probably there
are games like this that
in similar positions that where
black just resigned but there is a way
to
to save this game king b6
yes very good very good so there is a
way to to save this game by
by stalemate and
well if white manages to play a5 then
there is no more
okay there are still some stalemate
position but
the the game would be lost so it's
important to go
king b6 first just to notice not a6
because a5 so king b6
king king d6
and now we need to we need to prepare
the stalemate
of course uh if we move the king then we
just lose the c5 pawn
so as he said a6 is very good
and now white uh why can uh
spare a move king d5 and there we go
king a5
well if white goes to if the king goes
to d6
black just goes king b6 and basically
this is what black is doing
king b6 king a5 and if king takes c5
we got the stand rate so
as i said it's very uh
the stalemate is very useful in in
endings and i'm going to show you some
more examples with this
of course i don't want to show you the
very simple examples like
king pawn versus king with opposition
and
where they they just finishing uh in a
statement
but i'm trying to to show you some fun
examples and uh something more
interesting and
uh yeah soon well okay
let's move on to to the next example so
here we have
rook ending uh black is stuck on the
on the last rank and
white is uh threatening rook b8
well i i can share with you that it's
black's
move so if you want i can
i can flip the board yo
thank you thank you
so what is black going to do here
uh and you can write in the chat
room g7 only way to draw very good very
good
so it's again the stay mate that saved
the
that saves the day i just want to
mention that rook 8 is
this is just lost because it's the f
pawn and
probably the fastest way to win for
white i mean
this is the passive defense it would
work with the g pawn but
with the f pawn is just lost and now
there is this maneuver rook g7 jack
king there rook h7 king j8 f7
and it's all over
but black
has a saving move rook g7
and then if white doesn't take the rook
the
okay he can go back
or to to the second rank and it's uh
it's just a draw and if it takes on g7
then
again it's just a true so this uh
[Music]
this is a typical uh
uh a typical motive and
uh yeah like this it's easy to
it's easy to to see but during the game
um it's good to to just know it because
towards the end of the game players get
tired and
they are prone to to make mistakes
all right let's move on to more
slightly more difficult examples not
really difficult
i don't want to i don't really want to
show you difficult examples today
we're going to have some studies as well
so
how about this one
it's um oh in the previous one
if uh if white king
can grasp then
oh wait here well then just
[Music]
i guess rook rook g2 and then we can
give
we can give checks from from behind
and white cannot
cannot hide his king because
because the king the pawn is advanced
so there is no way if he goes here for
example you can just go here
and there is no way to
[Music]
to find the king so just check checks
and
all right let's move on to the next one
[Music]
i know both players so it's a game
between erdog victor
and uh amin bassem
played at the world cup the situation in
the first
game was a draw and this is the second
game
and uh in
the world cup they play two games and uh
the winner
moves on and in case of a tie they they
play some rapids
and then blitz bliss games and so on
so black is uh
black is completely winning here and uh
if he wins this game then he just uh
goes on to to the next stage
um white white is to move and um
let's see how how this game
[Music]
concluded so
in the game white uh gave a check
well it's it's just two pawns down and
uh
this rook ending is uh is simply lost
okay he tried to check
king 6 rook 8 and now
[Music]
black was a bit
black was not black was not careful of
course he knew
about this and uh this is very
uh easy stuff but he just uh
he heard it um he heard it and he played
a3 here with the point that if white
takes on a3 then there is check and the
rook
the rook is gone
um and uh
well what do you think white played here
[Music]
then
what did you do is the decisive game and
if you lose it
then you just go back home
because this is
this is the world cup so okay king d2
just lose on the long run because of
rook h3
or something and so on or some check
here for example king f5
but uh indeed the solution was
this one the pawn can simply be taken
and now we reach an elementary ending i
mean it's uh
rook ending and just this pawn doesn't
doesn't do anything and yes after check
this is the point indeed as
you as you already mentioned k4
and in the game okay he just took on a3
and we reached uh
we reached the desired uh stalwage
very nice tail mate in the just in the
middle of the board
uh yeah just just to say that king f3
or or other moves uh were not
were not really helping him so because
then
he can uh he can bring the king or
something it
it's just lost so only rook h3 was the
the solution uh yes afterwards they play
uh they play rapids and uh
erdos managed to qualify
so yeah it it cost him i mean it must
have been
very painful but uh yeah it's it's a
lesson i guess
it happens obviously they both knew
about this trick but
um yes the pressure
of the moment
so yeah very nice once again to show you
there we go
[Music]
okay let's move on to
let's move on to the next example
it's a game between hubner
robert hubner and andres adorian
and here again we have a choice with
black
so black is to move black is upon up
and
[Music]
what would you do in this ending okay
the
problem is that this uh these pawns are
stuck here
and the b5 is uh keeping both black
spawns
okay black is going this way and white
is going this way
so basically what would you do
how would you win this game
and not fall for tricks yes it's between
is between
[Music]
rook rook h3
and rook c5
so
rock h3 rock h3 is just
[Music]
rock h3 would have been the winning move
and now
the position is is just hopeless for
for white because uh he's going to
he's going to lose however in the game
black found black found a shortcut
this rook c5 because after rook c5 uh
the the king ending is
uh is completely one i mean after king
h4 there is c4 and
as you can see this is the square so
the king is not in time to get to the
pawn
it's too long away however
there was a trick
white had a last trick of his sleeve
that he used
and what could it be
ideas
very good very good
king hc okay king h6 just loses to rook
g5 so it's room g6 is not possible
because of the pin
no but rook h4 it's is good enough
for a draw so yeah rook h4
uh king king takes h4 and
now white uh i mean the material is
equal suddenly
and if rook takes g5 like it happened in
the game
uh we got the same weight again
so it can happen
it can happen just uh just about all the
time
this uh this time mate and uh
i have to tell you it's uh okay when you
manage to save a game by stellmate is
very good but
when it happens to you and then
that your opponent is
manages to get a stalemate trick then
it's very annoying because the game ends
immediately
and uh instead of winning you just
you just
make a draw yeah actually some players
some
strong players wanted to remove the
stalemate but
uh in order to have more concluded games
but
uh yeah it's i guess it's part of just
10 weight is part of chess
so yeah it's beautiful it's beautiful
and i will also show you some
some studies with the um
with the stalemate
okay let's move on to more practical
games
and we have this this game between
[Music]
wesley song with the white pieces and
sergey karjakin with black pieces
how could have black checkmated here
here where in this
game or
what do you mean okay let's uh let's
talk about this
this example it's why to move
and
the one before what
okay in the in the game before just
taking the pawn on h3 was
was a winning position
but for now let's uh
let's think about this one so
um it seems that white is doing very
well because uh
okay white is an exchange now but bishop
on d6 and pawn on e7
are just very strong the queen is stuck
here
nevertheless and um but okay there is no
way to
to break through here and um
no way to advance the pawn as yet and
the queen is stuck on
the queen stuck on the g6
so in the game why to move white uh
decided
to you would resign here
all right in the game white uh
also also i have to mention that it's
important the queen is on g6 because
it controls the king the king of f7
square so
white doesn't really want to take on e8
uh but instead he wants to keep the
queen here and wants to force black to
take
because after taking back let's say the
king is
doing just uh very bad there so it would
be lost i mean
white king goes forward
however things are not so okay the queen
cannot move
obviously because of e8 but
white also cannot cannot make any
progress and now he decides
to
to try his luck and uh he goes g5
when white is to play white white played
a very interesting move
g5 here there we go
g5 and now black has
black has a choice what to do well
not really a choice but my question to
you is
what do you play with black here well we
didn't get to the stand mate yet i mean
look at it there are plenty of pieces on
the board but it's still
uh it's still a good decision about how
to
how to defend here
queen takes queen
everybody would exchange queens well
exchanging queens is not uh
is not a good idea because look at this
uh take here for example then
okay for now e8 queen uh is a threat so
you have to
you have to put the rook there otherwise
it's just checkmate and look at this
take
here in the king g4
and you see the king is on its way and
once the
king reaches e6 it's the game is just
lost
so something else is required here
well it's not it's not really difficult
so he he has to take on g5
you cannot you cannot allow this this
pawn on g5
but how to
not not not immediately i mean we will
we will get
to that don't worry we will get to that
and believe me it will be nice but
for now it's just a normal position i
don't
[Music]
want to show you just the final
stalemate position
rookie seven is just uh you know
giving up a rook so let's not
give the rook like that
htac g5 yeah very good
this is what he played in the game so
just take the pawn
uh taken with the f pawn was also losing
i guess but it doesn't make any sense to
take with f pawn so
just going like this and now white
goes
h6 breaking through
well now there is a threat of checkmate
on g7
so
he has to he has to exchange the queens
he does it queen g6
takes yeah you have to take the queen
and now there is a threat of e8 uh rook
or
queen or whatever you have to stop it
rookie
yes exactly exactly exchange the queens
and then rookie
but now what was the the purpose of uh
white's moves white can go h7 check
only move of course king a chain well
already you can see that the king is on
a stalemate position but
the standby position is quite a
dangerous position i would say
because it's also very exposed to
checkmates so
yes it could be a stalemate but very
easily it could be a checkmate
also so just imagine uh this
rook gets to f8 or anyway white gets
access to the
last rank it's it's game over
immediately so it's a risky approach but
there was no no other way
[Music]
and now of course white is going towards
the
uh e6 yes this this was the game this
was the game
so white is uh heading towards e6 with
idea to go
all the way to f7 and
that's that's a winning position
how about now black has to remove his g5
pawn first to stain weight
yes how to how to remove pieces we need
to start removing pieces
here and we need to do it fast i guess
because
otherwise there will be
otherwise the king that passes and i
think when the king is
uh over there to f7 then it's just over
g5 and f6 yes this this bones should be
removed
if we want to talk about some some
stainmate ideas
but how
what should black do oh
some radical rook whatever rook takes on
e7 is just is just lost i guess
no it's too much material and then
uh white will uh yeah there are
ideas with bishop f6 no no that that is
just lost we cannot we cannot give the
rook
as yet for example okay here
i guess maybe even bishop
bishop takes bishop takes it's
just winning so
something else must be done
[Music]
push the pawn until white takes them
then sacrifice both rooks
very good f5 yes
this is the way to do it so f5 check
this was played
yes we need to remove the f pawn first
all right okay and now white has to take
uh
one of these pawns if it doesn't take
then the pawns are
are going to to advance anyway
so for example if uh in the game he took
the g5 one
but if he goes king f5 then just uh
g4 k6
uh g3 okay now the this pawn is quite
dangerous so it must be it must be taken
otherwise it can it can promote
so now this time of course now it's time
to give the
the rooks and um
well if y takes only 7 then it's just a
statement
if it goes to d6 then
[Music]
black will keep on giving checks and
the position is is drawn
okay so this happens if king takes f5
yes very very precise play but in the
game
wesley saw played king g5
while he said first remove g5 pawn and
we will see afterwards
and now it is uh
now he played okay maybe maybe
maybe there was a trick here actually
yes yes there could be a trick like this
so
i guess if for its uh
f4 could be too too soon
i'm not sure about it but maybe
well in the game he didn't play f4 yet
maybe there is a possibility to go
something like
rookie 5 rook f5 rook f8
something like this rookie 5 yeah
then f3 just look
look here and it look up then
f5 with the idea to build cafe
so i guess i'm not sure but
i guess f4 is a bit uh
too soon so in the game he played
rook b1 just to activate the rook and
the threat and checks
and as you see he is keeping the f5 pawn
in the
path of the king so if the king wants to
go further
it needs to take the pawn so
rk3 he played rook g1
well now there is no no other way but
to take the f5 pawn otherwise uh
if he goes here the g6 pawn can fall and
then the situation turns around
so king takes and
rookie one well
as you can see the eighth rank is uh
well defended by black
no problems over there and for now also
black is
keeping the e6 square so that
white cannot cannot
[Music]
go further with the king and now the the
position is just uh
just a draw white uh
made the waiting move and
probably if if black makes a waiting
move like rookie suite it's still a draw
but
how can you how can you force the events
what would you play
which which rook
um
rookie one takes e7 then there is uh
bishop takes
[Music]
e7 so that is wrong you need to take you
need to take
okay just to show this this and now
if you go rook f8 there could be
um king
e6 let's say okay for example there is
no rook f6 but maybe
[Music]
um i don't know maybe rook e8 but
it's not uh this is not the best the
best
is um
yeah that could be background issues
yeah rook
8 takes c7 was played very good
and now if rook 8 checked there is
rookie 8
so white took the bishop took the rook
yes rook rook 87 very good
and now what do you do black is
threatening
checkmate on the last rank so
what was the point checks on the ife
file yes
checks to infinity exactly very good
very good
rook rookie 5 and
[Music]
well in the game he just took on e5 with
the stalemate
i just i just want to show you that
there is no way to escape the checks for
example check check check
nowhere to go
bishop there you can just take the
bishop
or i don't know here there is rookie too
so stay animate again
so good game
and uh yeah very precise defense by
sergey karjakin
um
yeah the minister of defense
very very very nice example yes indeed
uh let's move on to to the next one it's
a game between uh
jakovenko and boris gelfand
let's put it from black's point of view
so it is white okay
it is white to move
black is threatening quincy to checkmate
so
there is only one way to to play here
which is running with the king towards
the center
but as we can see okay the key the black
king is in position i would say your
stainmate position but uh
actually objectively the position is
just lost for black
because uh he is too much material down
like how many pounds
four pounds down well you cannot save
such
such a position and also
if white manages to give some checks he
he will get a
mate attack queen of three well
is not so easy is not so easy
yes i like i like the idea of queen of
three but queen street just king of
three and uh
here well he can take whatever
and it's just lost so no queen of sweet
um well the normal move would be queen
g2 let's say
but then after king e3
22 let's say okay king g1 just
doesn't bring anything so yeah the king
is
going towards safety and i as we can see
the king will be safer where uh
once it gets out of the knights range
so the knight this is the knights range
this is
these are the squares controlled by the
knight and
as you can see once the king is getting
out of this range
then the queen alone won't be able to
to give checks to give checks uh
queen takes b2 let's say well 93 or
something then white
gets to give checks and i don't
i don't even want to to say what's going
to happen like
this this it's over so queen b2
king runs i mean white has too much
material and he can give up material
and you see now it's it's running away
from the night
just running away from the night this is
the pathway
here king c7 you see the king
running running and of course if white
gets the check as i said this just came
over
there and uh finally white can go
queen c8 and when black
moved the queen somewhere then white can
give a check
and it gives a check and then then it's
game over
so saying all this or
black uh sets up a trap and
how okay he goes i'll tell you the move
i will tell you the moves so the move is
black goes g4
very tricky yes very good very good g4
okay knight h3 the king would just uh
get away even king g3 and then there is
no
there is no chat so g4 is a tricky move
and now uh for better or worse white
doesn't have any check on the
last rank as you can see the queen is uh
controlling their everything so there is
no check there
and black is also threatening queen f3
with the
checkmate
so what do you think
what should i do here well white
considered that
[Music]
such a pawn must be must be taken
[Music]
so in the game white took i took on g4
uh padding the threat of queen queen of
three once and for all
actually the winning uh the winning move
whatever stuck which thinks yeah
there were several ways to win and one
of them was against
to run yes to run either way with the
king
e3 or king g3 for example king is three
there
and again uh it just runs and
once white gets to give checks it's it's
over
and also running here was uh
quite safe
because the the king will be able to
hide be
behind the pawns and there we go
there is no check it's game over
but it was a nice uh it was a nice try
definitely uh bishop d5
well bishop d5 it's too much i guess
you don't want to give that bishop
so in the game white
took on g4
and yeah we managed to get rid of the
pawn so now
we still have to get rid of two pieces
the knight and the queen
if we want to if we want to get
a stand mate so how are we going to do
it
obviously the most difficult will be to
get rid of the
knight i mean it's very easy to get rid
of the queen just play
queen a3 on something but how to get rid
of the knight
what would you play here
furious nigel well it's not
yeah it's not yet the time for night for
the knight to
to move here um
knight knight d7 how to play 97 this is
the seven square
i know in the game in the game black uh
king jason now black is tomorrow
it's uh black black to move here
queen g2 okay the game yes he played
queen g2 king is free
and now uh well queenie two
king f4 well it doesn't force that i
mean queen to
just be king d4 and we didn't manage to
get rid of the
of the knight but there is another move
here
very nice move of course
that um
king g3 95 very good 95 is the move
and it turns out that
[Music]
now black is able to to make a draw
uh in the game he didn't take the knight
not yet for example if bishop
d5 then just we we can just uh
start harassing the king and
we reached the standmate
the desired standmate
and um or else if uh
king d3 then just queen g3
and we
have a perpetual
but in the game white went
up with the king king d4
yes yes exactly and the knight
but look at this we had to reposition
the knight to
a central square to d5
and now he went uh not
22 actually i don't know why
[Music]
now he went to
[Music]
king okay queen d2 maybe
what could that be
yeah i think i think it could be good
good enough
queen yeah 22 could be could be good
enough actually
but in the game he played king f2
yeah i don't i don't see anything also
against
uh 22 yeah queen editor is probably good
enough
and now the the knight has to be taken
so king takes the
fight there is no there is no way to
escape
we can see that king c4 even loses to
fork here there's another fork
and well king e5 then just queen is
three yeah i
is the same with king 22 yeah
so he takes and now
what do we have
okay we managed to get rid of the
of the pawn of the knight and now
we need to we need to get rid of the
queen yeah 24
very good and also it's important to
open up this bishop because if we don't
uh
open up the bishop then it's not uh
crazy five yeah quincy five could be
working as well but
yeah in the game he played the queen d4
um and after king
takes it was a draw but otherwise just
king c6
um well queen c7
for example it's just it's again a draw
and if the king tries to run on the
other side
like king e6 then again
queen e5 here and
just a draw
well maybe even even queen of six i mean
there are several way
there are several ways yeah okay okay
that was just uh
that was just for a nice finish
so yeah interesting interesting example
and uh just to see that at this level
black managed to save
[Music]
a losing position and
yeah now i want to i want to show you
also gamma
that i played
i don't i don't know the the year
so i'm going to show you one of my games
um
well it happened also to me
but i have to say that we are both quite
low on time
in this game so i'm playing white
against alonso roselle
alvar it was the
catalan league played the play this year
so i sacrificed an exchange but
uh look at this i have this
[Music]
past pawn and the bishop is uh very
strong
it depends on if war is eyeing towards
the king
and uh yeah the black king is very weak
but as you can see there is a stalemate
motive
all right i wasn't aware of that during
the game so black to move
black goes um well we can see from my
point of view
anyway from white's point of view so in
the game black
goes h4 just to
you know get his attack going
i took the pawn i mean obviously i
cannot
i cannot allow such a pawn there and now
he is tricky he goes king queen f4 he
i was so i was so shocked that he
doesn't take on h4
well it turns out that queen takes h4
it's better for me
i'm not sure it's winning or not so the
line goes
like this queen takes e5 and then
g3 uh only move
and after some
after some exchanges okay it's it's
about
descending that
uh well he's going to take my a pawn but
i still have a bishop on three pawns and
also these moves are not easy to
easy to find so rook f21
okay so let's go back to this position
so
objectively and the only move i'm uh i
was calculating in the game
is obviously queen takes h4 i i cannot i
cannot think about any other move
but in the game
i mean it's logical you want to take on
h4 maybe
mount some attack on the h file who
knows
and in the game he goes queen f4
and now well now i'm even
this pawn up but obviously he's
threatening to go g3 one
one last trick you know so what
would you do here
with uh with white with white pieces
yes this is what i played in the game i
went g3
queen g3 yeah g3 g3 is the move
just terrorism of guys very good so
yes exactly this is what i did well
um let me just say that queen c3 was
actually winning because
black is not threatening anything like
g3
now i can i can just take
but yeah i found it g3 i went
because now the queen has to go back and
uh
even here it doesn't really disturb me i
can take one
on e5 so
we're cool winning position
however what happened
what can black do here
up to you queen takes g3 yeah
such a nasty surprise happened and when
well now i need to take the queen i have
to take the queen because
otherwise
yes so i had to take the queen
and now well i guess you you found the
idea
you know you know what check king g2
the other guy i had to take
here yeah very good well if king ji1
doesn't save because just rook f1 and
the king cannot escape
so there we go stand mate
well i was i was like really
yes yes we we analyzed after the game
yes we
we analyzed we talked about the game but
i was like really shocked because the
game could end with my
my victory and then just suddenly it
ended with
with a draw so but yeah
this is this is life i mean one has to
be careful about this
stand mate ideas because they are very
tricky
and of course when
[Music]
sometimes you can set traps with
stalemate ideas
so okay this is all about stalemates for
now
i have prepared even some studies and
other things very beautiful but
this is all for now i hope
i hope you enjoyed the the examples i
chose
i tried to show some practical
practical chess and
[Music]
thank you everybody for watching i'll be
right back with the
games of the week in a few minutes
bye bye for now thank you for watching